it has been a summer of blockbuster
flops from White House down and Olympus
has fallen World War Z didn't do as well
as people thought oblivion a little bit
before that
now the Lone Ranger is tanking they're
saying it's gonna lose like 150 million
bucks all the big boys and that's what
summer's are all about the big popcorn
flicks they're all crumbling and losing
money for the studio's I think there
might be something culturally good going
on here that we're starting for the
first time could it be possible that
Americans are getting sick of the giant
machine that pumps out transformers
Michael Bay crap endlessly I hope so I I
think and I think it's the same for
women I don't see big transformer movies
with the gobots or whatever and I don't
see rom-coms a lot of I'd prefer Gobots
but I think they're both they're both
lazy writing they neither neither side
of the spectrum appeals to me and I I
hope you're right and and these guys you
know the Will Smith's and the Tom
Cruise's and all this stuff they're not
they're not gods they're not invincible
they're not you know 50 plus right and
Brad Pitt's gonna be turning 50 Wilson
is 44 but still I mean he ain't well
he's always sort of been pegged as like
well with the young kid he can still act
like the 20-something and get away with
it in a movie yeah well actually after
earth was the one that I forgot to
mention and that was one of the biggest
bombs and I think part of it is directly
because of people how people are now
feeling about his son yeah do you think
that's part of it that it's like you
know most kids get like you know a toy
or a video game for their birthday his
son got a movie like here take this
movie do you think part of this is like
people are starting to turn against the
big stars a little bit I think some look
I'm I'm a movie goer so I go see all the
big movies I still go see independent
movies and stuff too but you know I
think like with Johnny Depp there's been
a lot of stories Lone Ranger has tanked
it hasn't affected Disney stock which I
thought was very interesting because
they said a few months ago that the
investors actually thought it's probably
gonna be a tank because people were not
reviewing it well and I'm thinking wow
they're okay without
sixty million dollar loss they've
already like accepted that into their
right so much but but when people are
talking about Johnny Depp as an actor
and probably these other guys it's like
a they're they're just kind of mailing
it in which has become like okay what
happened to the Johnny Depp of old that
was like the quirky guy but that had
some substance behind his really cool
characters now he's just flopping his
arms and doing the same couldn't sort of
Pirates of the Caribbean stick in the
Lone Ranger when it looks like it's just
a different costume like they had which
you know I think people are getting
sicker and then be the rioting all we're
doing now is seeing remakes of past
movies or past TV shows and I'm thinking
to myself I mean the last great movie
that I really really really liked was
that was original was inception and I
was like what it was a fantastic movie
that you had to watch a couple times
think you gotta think about all the way
to the very end and even then you're
having discussions and it was like oh my
god it was a it was an original movie
idea with great acting a great storyline
it made you think you had to stay
focused through the entire movie instead
of these like you know I don't know how
many Superman's are we doing and how
many transformers are we doing I'm like
people are getting sick of that I think
people are like oh my god another we
ready first movie yeah I mean really
there's already ready to think there's
an app called run pee I know if you're
familiar but it basically tell you we're
in the movie you can go pee and not miss
anything
just pee gonna miss anything and I you
know it to be honest that's like I said
it's not really my kind of movie I did
see World War Z yeah that was great yeah
I thought it was great it was I am
Legend evideos cool whatever but I gotta
say as far as apocalyptic movies are
concerned this is the end the best
malaria because the writings great the
banter is funny the story I didn't ever
realize it was like a stupid zombie
movie until halfway through and that
proves the point though because that was
a smart well-written yeah well it's not
on this list of massive budget
because there's no really big movie
action stars like these guys you know in
it but it big ensembles great the
writing's funny yeah everything about it
is this kind of tongue-in-cheek but it
was original this money and maybe you
know with stuff like Breaking Bad
Walking Dead maybe we are getting
smarter that's perfect yeah Dish Network
whatever you do that's that's private up
to you but I think you're on it with
that about this idea that there's so
much good television right now you know
a to me in between and if you want to
get your zombies you can watch Walking
Dead and it's great and Breaking Bad or
what's the other way what's the other
one what's the one on Netflix with Kevin
Spacey how's the car you were like if he
didn't I wouldn't know what a whip was
so I have to you know you're talking
about how swim yeah yeah so all right
Matt on your porn channel tonight
I'm finding this rather inspiring we all
seem to be agreeing that maybe Americans
are ready for some smarter could it
possibly be and you know what the the
one thing over anything in any situation
if you talk with your checkbook or you
talk with your wallet people will have
to listen up and you win when they said
oh you know maybe friend dependent today
we're not gonna hire Will Smith because
you know what he's diminishing in how
fans like him and really can we afford
that paycheck
finally a move a movie production
company that's going you know maybe it's
not worth it mark finally in case you're
this a no yes so Independence Day to is
not going to have Will Smith in case
which is great I mean why not have
somebody new yeah you know I mean again
it's another you know sequel to another
movie which is driving me crazy can't we
just right I mean where are the writers
in Hollywood really the write something
original but then they're like most
exactly right exactly I mean with the
upstart of great cable television shows
but you know all of the regular you know
free TV you know dramas are really in
comedies of you know they've all
disappeared over the years
we're friends there's no wearing shows
like that and it's like writers are like
oh we have nothing else to work on
everything's reality and I'm like well
if you're writing really good quality
stuff filling prophecy we can still turn
the ship around you know I don't hold it
against the big stars I mean get your
paycheck man putting it that's any of
them yeah but on the other hand it's
like well humorous like you're not maybe
you're not you're not worth that anymore
I didn't this article actually that you
sent us Tom Cruise has were gone like a
movie that he agreed to so we could go
back and make another Mission Impossible
movie cuz he knows that's that's the
cash cow that's the moneymaker right I
actually thought Oblivion was pretty
decent but and then by the time we
blinked and my husband came back from a
trip it was it was not in the movie
theater anymore
well final point of this do you think
that's actually part of the problem that
everyone gets so hyped for these big
movies that if you don't see it in the
first two days it's like still there
it's still there but it's like oh I
already missed the exciting you're about
it like people are like oh it sucks and
then people go yeah you know I want to
spend my twenty dollars at the movie
theater then I'll go see something else
that I've heard is good
you're a real movie buff you give it to
them that first weekend because that's
all that anybody gives a [ __ ] about you
know hi you don't really want to help
but then soon enough you're gonna get it
on Netflix oh you're gonna get it on DVD
or you're gonna watch it on HBO anyway
so a lot of times people I've asked my
friends Mike hey have you gone see
bubble blinds in the movie theater no
I'll just wait for it come out I'll
watch it at home it's like you know
unless it's such a great movie that you
have to see it on the big screen but all
the bells and whistles he's like no I'll
just wait for it to come out on DVD yeah
like really you never used to be that
way
you know what I in these here parts we
appreciate you watching it on YouTube so
there's a subscribe button right down
there I want to thank my guest Lee ant
Whedon and Gina grad there on the
Twitter and you can see their little
Twitter handles right there as well and
now you can go back to your redtube as
we and recommend it or you can go into
your internet browser thing and block
all that stuff as the man from the
man horn and thing doesn't want you to
do okay we'll do this again next week
thanks